looks like a buzzsaw donut well it's not
it's a rotifer a teeny-tiny aquatic
animal and I mean teeny tiny most
species don't grow bigger than a
hundredth of an inch long those spinning
parts are the business end of the
critter they're known as cilia by
rapidly beating these to learn fur
creates a vortex that sucks in food
check this out
oops missed it got that one the broad
four ain't picky about what it eats
animal material plant material wetter
some species tend to more gnaw on things
once it's got a hold of food the rotifer
grinds his stuff up with a little jog it
even had a stomach to digest the grub
and critically an anus to expel the
waste those beating cilia also help
propel the rotifer around though some
species simply stick to one spot and
wait for food to come to them pretty
neat right well you may be able to get
some rotifers of your own they're
everywhere
even damp soil in your backyard just
drop some dirty water with a pipette and
apply it to a slot put the slime under a
microscope and he'll probably catch
sight of a rotifer too
well Camden